let's get right to hatred mail this week
quick reminder what is hatred mail it's
like a mandatory transvaginal ultrasound
for your mind Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom ok this
hatred mail I say this like it's unusual
this hatred mail contains some
contradictions let's see if you can spot
them as we listen together Pakman is a
lying cunning Jew no mr. Pakman you nor
anyone alive can be 100% Jew why well
before there were Jews around Homo
sapiens was already out there since Jews
arose from people that we're not you
cannot be 100% if you claim you are you
must proof that the very first people
were Jewish and that nowhere along a
millions of years long line that was
delighted to even the smallest extend
and that is without even considering
that we arose from quitters that were
not humans down to the very first living
thing lot of confusion here I'm a lying
cunning Jew and also Jews don't really
exist according to this person which is
which is fascinating a contradiction as
much as anti-semitism staples of of
hatred mail that we receive remember the
best way to fight hate reott ISM is to
use the coupon code hate free at 40 and
grab a membership at join pakman.com
when you do that you are supporting us
you're getting 40% off with the coupon
code hatred 40 and it makes hay tree
it's cry it's like a dream where you're
just trying to punch someone and you
can't you can't land a blow that's what
it feels like to a hatred when they
write in these screeds and then people
just sign up with the coupon code hey
tree at 40 so take advantage of it